η επαγγελματική από κατάσταση μετά και από κάποιες επιτυχίες είναι αυτό πο αρμόζει σε ένα
άθλητη με τος επιτυχίας διαδή το κράτος είναι δίπλα στους αθλητες στέτεται υπαγγελματιά απου κατάσταση
ίχε σταματήζω το δχει λιες δύο το παλιώ σέα που λέγαμε το τ λιασε εφθά
όταν πήρα το πρώτο μου παγκόσμο μετάλλιον στην οσάκα στην ουσίν και με σολάβιση του
προέδρου τότε το αμνος του παγαδόπουλου μεσολάβισαν οη καταστάσεις για να πάρουμε επαγγελομεγιο κατάσταση νεγώ
και ο αν δεν κανόλαυοσκο γόρους αχιλέως που στην ουσία είχαμε και εγώ προσωπικά ταν
μεκαλύτερη πιτυχία της κύπρου σε ατομικό άθημα οπότε πήρα με την επαγγελμαγια υγατάσταση το τιολιι
κά οκτώ επαναφέραν την επαγγεματικα ποράσταση μου πολύ πιο ψηλακριτιαριά δηαδή νομίζω ενι μεχριόχδο εθέση
ν όλη εμπιακούς και όγυ το υμπαγκόσμε πορδάθημα θεωρώ ότι είναι ένα καλό βήμα ότι
επανήλρθε αλλά δεν μπορείς να βάλει τις κριτήριονόδος και ογδος παγκόσμο και ολεμπιάα δεν είμαστε
ιαγόρα που έουμε πολούς όλι πιωνί καιση έχουμε πολύ πληθαστεροαθλητές που έχουν περισσότερες ευκαιρίες σίγουρα
αυτό που το άγγελμα του προέτρου για των αφιλητισμόν του προετού της δημορατίας του γύρχο
το δουλίδη όσι λαμπάνουν μέρο τις όλιν μπιακούς αγόνες θα παίρνουν επαγγελομα για γαράσταση απόδο
και πέρα είναι κάτι πολύ θετικό θεωρώ ότι πρέπει να ευπάρχουν κινήτρα δεν μπορεί κάποιος
αθήτης να τρϊόλη του της ζωή τα καλύτερα του χρόνια να φαίνει διακρίσεις ιστοκάτωκάτω είναι
μεκαλύτερ διαθημησεη της χώρας μας δεναι δεν έχει από αλον αδιαφημιστή χώρα μας γι κάτι
καλόν έσι γιατί για άλλα έχουμε δοξε τοθεών αρκετά διαφημιστεί οπότε θεωρώ υπάρχει πρέπει να
υπάρχει ή επιβράβευση και το κίνητρο αν δεν έχει κίνητρα κάποιον παιδί ι κάποιος αθλετής
σίγουρα δεν εκειτόσον μεγάλον το ενδιαφέρων όμως παρένθεση τα κίνηται